des établissements contraints de fermer
leurs portes alors que débute ce mardi
la période de jeûne annuelle chez les
musulmans qui représentent plus de 90%
de la population turque face à la
flambée des quatre commises dans le pays
le gouvernement a choisi de fermer les
bars et les restaurants une restriction
vivement contesté par les professionnels
du secteur qui estiment que le ramadan
n'est qu'un prétexte
le ramadan est une excuse
la fermeture n'a rien à voir avec le
ramadan c'est comme la politique en
général les bars le personnel des bars
des musiciens toutes les personnes qui
vivent dans ce secteur sont dans une
situation difficile
ils ne sont pas en mesure de payer les
loyers des salles ne peuvent pas être
payés
la plupart des lieux ont dû fermer
pendant le mois de ramadan les
restaurants bars et cafés ne pourront
proposer que des plats à emporter ou des
livraisons à domicile
problème tous les établissements
n'offrent pas ce genre de service
certains sont donc contraints de stopper
totalement leurs activités nous devons
fermer il n'y a rien à faire à partir de
demain ou ferme
ils disent que les plats à emporter sont
autorisés mais comme nous ne servons pas
de plats à emporter
nous devons fermer
vingt personnes travaillaient ici nous
avons dû réduire nos effectifs
maintenant il y en a que deux mais ce
n'est pas comme si quelque chose se
passait nous attendons mais il n'y a pas
de clients dans le même temps les
autorités ont fermé les mosquées aux
prières de tarawih ce une prière
collective effectuée chaque soir pendant
toute la durée du ramadan
d'après l'université johns hopkins la
turquie a enregistré un peu moins de 4
millions de cas de kobe de 19 et a
dépassé les trente quatre mille décès
depuis le début de la pandémie